when I first saw the trailer for this
movie I thought it looked sauce turns
out it's actually pretty sweet the
opening scene is set in Montauk New York
where a tow truck driver named Gary
arrives at his ex-girlfriend Maddie's
house to take away her car and is
revealed that her car is being
repossessed as she owes property taxes
on a home she inherited from her mother
Maddie holds two jobs one as a bartender
and the other as an Uber driver and
losing her car means losing her ability
to work as an Uber driver as a result
she tries to persuade Gary to spare her
car she even tries to appeal to his
feelings but her efforts are ruined by
another guy whom she hooked up with the
previous night seeing this Gary fastens
her car to his tow truck and leaves
don't worry Gary we're all jealous now
Carlos Maddie resorts to rollerblading
to make it to work along the way she
notices Gary's tow truck parked outside
a coffee shop seeing that he is busy
inside Maddie quickly unfastens her car
and tries to drive away however she
forgets that it remains Tethered to the
truck this results in a minor commotion
and Gary quickly arrives at the scene
and raises the car back up Maddie ends
up on probation as a result of her
actions but thankfully she is bailed out
by her friend named Gabe following this
Maddie rushes to her job at a bar with
her frustration still lingering she is
further annoyed when a customer demands
a drink before the bar is officially
open as a result she gets into an
argument with the customer causing her
to be scolded by her manager Fern Fern
then assigns Maddie the task of folding
napkins there she is accompanied by her
pregnant co-worker Sarah and her husband
Jim who's low-key the best part of this
movie as the three engage in Chit Chat
Sarah shows her a peculiar job
opportunity from wealthy cryptocurrency
investors the Beckers they are currently
searching for someone to date their
introverted 19 year old son Percy and in
return they're offering their Buick
Regal car as compensation this is about
as much a coincidence as it should be
illegal desperate to avoid losing the
home Maddie decides to accept this
unusual Craigslist post the next day she
visits the rich parents house in order
to discuss the job the parents Laird and
Allison tell her about their son who is
shy and doesn't have any experience with
girls drinking parties or sex they hope
to boost his confidence before he
attends Princeton University in the fall
as their discussion unfurls just as the
Willy of their son hopefully will the
pair learns that Maddie is already 32
which makes them somewhat hesitant if
the genders were flipped this would be
dark but they're not so it's hot
nonetheless Maddie asserts that what
they truly need is not a young girl but
someone mature who can guide their son
towards being a responsible man this
convinces the parents and they
eventually hire her for the job but
before departing they ask her not to let
Percy know about this later on Maddie
dresses up in a seductive dress and
heads to an animal shelter home where
Percy volunteers she fans interest in
adopting a dog and specifically demands
Percy's assistance with it Percy then
shows her a dog named Milo and starts
briefing her about its details Maddie on
the other hand keeps on hitting on him
in an attempt to flirt however Percy
doesn't feel comfortable due to which he
decides to end their conversation Maddie
who needs more time to talk to him
offers him a ride home Percy seems to be
hesitant but she grabs his bicycle and
loads it into the van which she borrowed
from Jim on their way Maddie tries to
strike a proper conversation during
which she cracks a joke referring to
Percy as her hostage the young boy takes
this seriously and thinks that she is
trying to kidnap him his suspicion Rises
when Maddie takes a different route
citing it as a shortcut in an attempt to
seek help Percy tries to dial 9-1-1 on
his phone but Maddie takes it away
heightening his unease a short while
later they arrive at Maddie's residence
and just before exiting the Van Percy
pepper sprays her face despite the pain
and Maddie expresses that she finds him
hot and wants to spend more time with
him hearing this Percy helps her wash
her face and the two agree to meet for a
date the following evening Maddie
invites Percy to a bar and the boy
arrives there in a suit with short pants
Maddie then orders a cocktail for both
of them Percy spits at the drink as soon
as he tastes it but Maddie tries to
convince him saying that he must try
alcohol before going to college their
conversation is soon interrupted by some
pool balls and then by one of Maddie's
ex-boyfriends he mentions that he is now
married and boasts that his wife is very
loyal unlike Maddie before departing the
man also warns Percy saying that she's a
slipper I don't know what that means
after their drinks Maddie takes Percy to
the beach and suggests that they go
skinny-dipping seeing him reluctant
Maddie undresses herself in front of him
and jumps into the water following this
Percy nervously takes off his clothes
and follows her soon after a group of
drunken teenagers show up and begin to
mock them they even try to steal their
clothes and other things Furious Maddie
walks out of the water naked and fights
the drunkards she beats the hell out of
them even going as far as to suplex one
of their dumb little balls and then goes
back to Percy all respect to Jennifer
Lawrence that scene was Bonkers after
witnessing her violent actions Percy is
scared of Maddie and as a result he
demands to be taken home however she
claims that it was only self-defense
brushing off this topic Maddie tries to
make out with him but the latter refuses
as he doesn't know her yet this annoys
Maddie who then leaves grabbing both of
their belongings a naked Percy follows
her and demands his clothes and phone
back but Maddie only gives him his
clothes she prepares to drive away but
Percy jumps on the van's Hood demanding
his phone never take a naked zoomer's
phone regardless Maddie doesn't care and
begins to drive only to be spotted by
the police this makes her worried as she
is already on probation frightened that
she will lose her license Maddie speeds
up the vehicle and manages to outrun the
police car by driving past an oncoming
train in the aftermath the two of them
go to her house and Maddie tries to
seduce him one more time she also starts
dancing on his lap but the inexperienced
Percy finds her heavy Maddie then places
him in her lap and starts to get close
unfortunately this only triggers Percy's
anxiety causing him to develop a rash on
his back despite this setback Maddie
doesn't judge him and instead nurses him
with some lotion comforted by her
kindness Percy opens up about his lonely
life he reveals how his classmates used
to mock him for sleeping in his parents
bedroom which is one of the reasons that
discourages him from socializing in
response Maddie also shares her story
regarding how she has lived in this
house her whole life to take care of her
sick mother Percy asks about her father
to which she says that he abandoned them
for his new family in the city after a
heart-to-heart conversation the two
decide to date before getting intimate
for the next few days Maddie and Percy
spend most of their time together
enjoying activities like beach outings
with their pets and playing laser tag in
the arcade as time passes Percy becomes
more at ease with Maddie and they form a
true friendship one day they both admit
to never having attended a prom Percy
wonders why she hasn't been to a prom
despite her prom queen attitude Maddie
replies that she once had written a
letter to her father asking why he
didn't want to see her however the
letter came back unopened just before
prom night this experience left her
feeling dejected so she opted not to
attend her story touches Percy's heart
so he asks for her permission before
kissing her afterwards the duo meets
with Percy's former Nanny named Jody who
is a little concerned to see Percy with
a girl in a playful manner he tosses a
Frisbee and asks Percy to retrieve it
while the boy is away Jody asks Maddie
if she is using Percy for money our girl
immediately shuts him up by saying that
she just wants to date him and that his
relationship with the kids a little
weird itself later in the evening Maddie
is at home when the doorbell rings
answering it she discovers her former
classmate named Doug Khan who is now a
real estate agent he cautions her about
the legal proceedings related to the
Takeover of her house but Maddie remains
Resolute in her determination to hold on
to it the same night Percy picks up
Maddie in his limousine and they go for
dinner at an expensive restaurant
treating it as their makeshift prom
night while enjoying their meal they
engage in Lively conversation cracking a
lot of dirty jokes shortly after Maddie
knowing that he likes music encourages
him to play the piano although initially
nervous Percy musters up his courage and
plays the song man-eater capturing
everyone's attention with his frankly
unbelievable Talent he turns out to be
so good that the entire crowd cheers for
him Percy then returns to Maddie who is
flabbergasted but soon after he is
approached by his school friend Natalie
after a brief chat she invites him to a
party Maddie appears somewhat jealous of
their interaction so she answers that
they're busy tonight despite this Maddie
provides him with the party address
before leaving in the next scene Percy
brings up the subject of his college
plans and is worried that they might not
get a chance to meet he asks if she can
visit him during weekends but Maddie
claims that she doesn't do long distance
hearing this the boy gets so upset that
he leaves the dinner and heads to
Natalie's party fearing that he might
sleep with other girls and ruin her job
Maddie follows him inside however she
loses him in the crowd so she asks the
party-goers about him instead of helping
her the youngsters mock her for coming
to the teen's party despite being old
eventually Maddie manages to locate
Percy in a room with Natalie but he's
sick because he has taken an ibuprofen
with alcohol concerned Maddie takes him
to the bathroom and forces him to vomit
this causes a scene at the party so
Natalie's father throws them out of the
place but not before Percy accident
evidently punches her in the throat it's
a stupid joke sold exceptionally well on
their way back Percy says that he is
ready to make out with her he takes out
some preventative measures but at the
same time he also confesses his love
towards her this makes Maddie
uncomfortable so she brushes it off by
saying that he's drunk and that they
shouldn't do anything tonight the
following morning Laird and Allison are
happy to notice that their son is now
more upbeat and extroverted thanks to
his so-called girlfriend however their
facial expressions change when Percy
shares his decision of not going to
Princeton because he wants to stay close
to Maddie the parents tell him to go for
car driving practice while they
immediately make a call to Maddie she
claims that she can't carry out the job
any further because Percy has gotten way
too attached to her in response Laird
offers her the car if she convinces him
to go to Princeton unbeknownst to them
Percy accidentally connects the car
Bluetooth to the phone and overhears
their conversation which shatters his
heart he takes some time to come to
terms and then invites Maddie to have
dinner with his parents once she arrives
Percy tries to make his parents and
Maddie have a conversation however they
somehow managed to play along shortly
after Percy receives a call from his
friend so he excuses himself from the
dinner the two friends then drive the
luxurious Buick Regal car to the woods
and destroy it Upon returning home Percy
heads straight to his room sensing
something amiss Maddie approaches him to
ask about the matter instead of
responding Percy leans in for a kiss but
Maddie refuses he then presses her to
disclose the truth but she continues to
lie with no other choice she agrees to
sleep with him to give him what he wants
unfortunately Percy doesn't last for
more than 10 seconds that was my thighs
she says no Percy as the two lay down
beside each other he finally admits that
he knows about her deal with his parents
hearing this Maddie apologizes to him
saying that their friendship was real
however a betrayed Mercy doesn't listen
and asks her to leave afterwards Percy
confronts his parents with the truth
insisting that they stop intervening in
his life and allow him to face both
success and failure independently now
that his relationship has ended Percy
reverts to his normal routine and begins
to spend his days in his room playing
video games on the other hand Maddie
receives the damaged Buick Regal as her
compensation which she starts using for
her Uber job passengers are a bit unsure
about getting into it but Maddie manages
to convince them to get in after several
days of hard work she makes enough money
to pay off her debts there's no way she
made that much money that fast she
happily celebrates this achievement with
Sarah and Jim however her Joy is
short-lived when she learns that Sarah
and Jim are soon moving to Florida
because they can't afford to buy a house
in Montauk that's more realistic later
on Maddie takes some time to reflect on
her life and decides to amend her
wrongdoings before moving on she burns
down the letter she wrote to her father
apologizes to Gary for what she did and
makes a bold decision to sell the house
she also wants to reconcile with Percy
but he doesn't reply to her calls or
messages as a result she drives towards
Percy's house only to learn that he's
visiting his university before enrolling
there Maddie then drives to Princeton
and apologizes to him for the Betrayal
when Percy tries to leave without
listening to her she jumps on the car's
Hood despite this he starts driving just
like she did in the past unable to see
Percy hits something that causes
Maddie's jacket to catch fire in a state
of panic he drives towards the sea to
set the fire out and then rushes to help
her in the aftermath of this event
Maddie's not dead which is crazy and the
two finally reconcile and share an
emotional hug as the car is being towed
the duo sits on the beach and shares
their future plans Percy is going to
Princeton while Maddie is moving to
California however they promise to stay
friends afterwards Maddie decides to
sell the house to Jim and Sarah so that
they don't have to move to Florida in
the final scene Maddie offers Percy a
personal Uber ride to Princeton on her
way to California she also discloses
that she has adopted Milo the movie ends
as the duo leaves the city to start a
new chapter of their lives see I told
you it was sweet subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching